[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Gary: IT TAKES AN INCREDIBLE
TEAM EFFORT TO WIN THIS ONCE,
BACK-TO-BACK, LET'S DO THIS THE
WAY WE DID IT LAST SEASON.
EVERYONE COME ON UP.
[ Apause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Chris: THE LIGHTNING ASKED TO
BE AROUND THE CUP LAST YEAR WHEN
THEY RECEIVED IT AND MAYBE THE
START OF A SPECIAL NEW
TRADITION.
>> Craig: AND INCREDIBLE LAST
YEAR THAT ERIE SILENCE AND NOW
THE FANS ARE WAITING TO EXPLODE
ONCE AGAIN.
>> Gary: AND WE HAVE THE
BACK-TO-BACK STANLEY CUP
CHAMPIONS.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Gary: IT REQUIRES A GREAT
ORGANIZATION, STARTING WITH JEFF
VINIK, JULIAN BRISEBOIS AND JON
COOPER, AND THESE INCREDIBLE
PLAYERS WHO HAD TO SACRIFICE AND
TO WORK HARDER UNDER THE MOST
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES, NOT
JUST THIS SEASON BUT LAST SEASON
AND THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Gary: AND I KNOW THAT I SPEAK
FOR ALL OF THE PLAYERS, AND THEY
DID AN INCREDIBLE JOB AS AN
INCREDIBLE TEAM BUT I SPEAK FOR
ALL OF THEM WHEN THEY SAY THAT
SHARING THIS WITH YOU HAS BEEN
THE HIGHLIGHT OF THIS CAMPAIGN
AND THE BACK-TO-BACK TROPHIES,
THANK YOU, FANS IN TAN
[ Applause ]
>> Gary: CAPTAIN STEVEN STAMKOS,
IT IS MY HONOUR TO PRESENT YOU
WITH THE STANLEY CUP.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Chris: ENCORE PERFORMANCE BUT
THIS ONE MIGHT BE EVEN SWEETER
AS HE SHARES IT WITH ALL OF
TAMPA BAY.
>> Craig: WITH ALL OF TAMPA BAY,
ALL OF HIS TEAMMATES AND BEING
ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE ON THE ICE
AND UNLIKE LAST YEAR, HAVING TO
DO MOST OF IT OFF.
>> Chris: AND JEAN BÉLIVEAU HAD
STARTED THAT TRADITION OF THE
VICTORY LAP WITH THE CUP SO THAT
FANS COULD GET A CLOSER LOOK AND
STEVEN STAMKOS WILL START THE
VICTORY PARADE AND WE'LL FIND
OUWHO IS GOING TO GET IT NEXT.
>> Craig: NOT A SURPRISE THERE,
VICTOR HEDMAN, NO QUESTION ABOUT
HIS IMPACT ONCE AGAIN.
>> Chris: 282 DAYS AFTER WINNING
THEIR FIRST, AND SO IT WILL BE
THE SHORTEST TIME SPAN BETWEEN
CUCTORIES.
AND DAVID SAVARD, HE GETS TO
RAISE THE CUP FOR THE FIRST TIME
AND ONE OF THE FEW
PART OF THIS TEAM A YEAR AGO.
>> Craig: YOU MENTIONED IT
EARLIER, CHRIS, SAVARD, ONE OF
THE RARE ONES WHO DID NOT HAVE
IT AND YOU FELT LIKE YOU WERE
LEFT OUT AND A FITTING HANDOFF
TO SAVARD.
>> Chri WITH AN ASSIST ON THE
GAME WINNING GOAL HERE TONIGHT.
>> Craig: A HEARDBREAKING LAST
FEW GAMES HERE FOR ALEX KILLORN,
DOING WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO TO
WIN, CHRIS, BLOCKING A SHOT.
THE REACTION OF THIS CROWD
KNOWING THAT HE WAS NOT ABLE TO
PLAY IN THE LAST FEW GAMES BUT,
OH, BOY, HAS HE HAD AN IMPACT
AND HE IS A REAL IMPACT PLAYER
ON THIS TEAM.
>> Chris: AND WE FOUND OUT HOW
IMPORTANT HE WAS BECAUSE
THAT LINE WAS NOT THE SAME AND
JON COOPER MENTIONED THAT HE GOT
THE FANS GOING IN WARMUPS AT THE
BELL CENTRE BECAUSE IT WAS IN
HIS HOMETOWN BUT HE WAS NOT
READY TO RETURN AFTER HE WAS
INJURED ON A SHOT BLOCK BUT ONE
OF THE CORE GUYS WHO HAS LED TO
THE BACK-TO-BACK CHAMPIONSHIPS
AND ANOTHER GUY HERE, VERY
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE CORE.
>> Craig: AND KEVIN BIEKSA SAID
IT, 162 PLAYOFF GAMES, THAT IS
TWO SEASON'S WORTH OF THE
HARDEST HOCKEY THAT YOU WILL
PLAY AND I THOUGHT THAT HE IS
CONTINUALLY GETTING BETTER AND
HE HAD JUST AN EXCEPTIONAL
STANLEY CUP FINAL, MAKING BIG
PLAYS, BOTH ENDS OF THE ICE AND
RIGHT THERE, THE PAYOFF WITH
THAT SMILE ON THE FACE AND IT
WILL BE ON THERE FOR A WHILE, I
THINK.
>> Chris: OH, BOY, THAT
DEFENSIVE CORE, SPECIAL, AND NOW
A GUY WITH A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
DOING THIS.
THE THIRD STRAIGHT FOR PAT
MAROON, A FIRST SINCE EDDIE
LITZENBERGER IN THE 1960s, AND
DONALD THE OTHER IN THE MORN
HISTORY OF THE CUP TO HAVE THREE
STRAIGHT.
>> Chris: AND HE WAS STRESSING
TO HIS TEAMMATES THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THREE IN A ROW AND HE KNEW
THAT IT WOULD BE SPECIAL TO WIN
TWO IN A ROW.
>> Craig: AND JUST NO PROBLEM
FROM GAME ONE OF THESE PLAYOFFS,
KUCHEROV, MAKING HIS IMPACT FELT
AND TWO GOALS, AN ASSIST AND
SETTING THE STAGE FOR WHERE WE
ARE RIGHT O AN KUCHEROV IN
THESE PLAYOFFS.
>> Chris: HE HAS PROVEN ONCE
AGAIN THAT HE IS ONE OF THE
ELITE TALENTS IN THE LEAGUE AND
LED THE CLUB IN SCORING IN THE
FINALS IN BACK-TO-BACK YEARS AND
ONLY MARIO LEMIEUX AND WAYNE
GRETZKY HAVE DONE THAT AND FROM
ONE RUSSIAN STAR TO ANOTHER.
[ Applause ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Chris: A GUY WHO, SOMEHOW,
JUST HAD MONTREAL'S NUMBER AND,
AGAIN, ONLY HAS LOST ONCE TO
MONTREAL SINCE 2018 AND EVEN IN
THAT GAME HE WAS ALMOST
UNBEATABLE.
>> Craig: JUST INCREDIBLE, ISN'T
IT?
THE 11th TIME IN 23 GAMES, A
GOAL OR LESS.
>> Chris: AND IT IS BACK-TO-BACK
CUPS FOR LUKE SCHENN AFTER HIS
BROTHER HAD WON IN 2019 AND SO
TONIGHT IN SASKATOON, THEY ARE
CHEERING AS WELL AND TWO CUP
RINGS FOR LUKE SCHENN WITH A
COUPLE OF SONS, KINGSTON AND
WESTON AND THIS IS A GUY AS
UNDERRATED AS ANYONE IN THE
LEAGUE.
>> Craig: AND I LOVE JON
COOPER'S POINTS SAYING THAT IF I
HAD TAKEN PALAT OFF OF THE LINE
OF POINT AND KUCHEROV AND POINT
AND KUCHEROV WOULD BE IN MY
OFFICE JUST MINUTES LATER ASKING
ME WHAT THE HECK AM I DOING AND
HE HAD SHOWN AN UNREALPHYSICAL
EDGE IN THIS SERIES AS WELL.
>> Chris: AND WHAT A STORY TYLER
JOHNSON IS.
AND IS THIS HIS LAST GAME IN
THIS UNIFORM?
HE LEFT HIS MARK, AN OUTSTANDING
STANLEY CUP FINAL, A COUPLE OF
GOALS IN GAME NUMBER THREE FROM
A GUY WHO WAS ON WAIVERS MORE
THAN ONCE THIS YEAR AS THEY HAD
TRIED TO SORT OUT THE CAP,
STARTING WITH JON COOPER AND HIS
AMERICAN LEAGUE TEAM AND ONLY
HAVING PLAYED FOR JON COOPER.
>> Craig: AND YOU JUST WONDER IF
THIS LINE COULD GO THREE IN A
ROW RIGHT HERE AND YOU THINK OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THIS TAMPA
TEAM AND JULIAN BRISEBOISth
NOW IS ONE OF THOSE, THIS INLOW
OF GOODROW, COLEMAN AND GOURDE,
JUST INCREDIBLE.
>> Chris: AND HANDING IT OFF TO
HIS CENTRE ICEMAN AS WE HAND IT
OFF TO KYLE.
>> Kyle: STEVEN STAMKOS,
THINKING OF THE DAY THAT YOU
WERE DRAFTED BY THE
ORGANIZATION, YOU SAID THAT YOU
COULD NOT BELIEVE THAT IT WAS
HAPPENING, CAN YOU BELIEVE THAT
YOU ARE NOW A BACK-TO-BACK
STANLEY CUP CHAMPION?
>> IT IS INCREDIBLE TO DO THIS,
TOGETHER, BACK-TO-BACK AND TO DO
IT NOW THIS YEAR INCOME FRONT OF
FANS, FRIENDS AND FAMILY, HUGE
MOTIVATION TO DO IT AGAIN, NOT
TAKING ANYTHING AWAY FROM LAST
YEAR BUT TO DO IT AGAIN IT IS
VALIDATION INTO HISTORY AND THIS
GROUP ACCOMPLISHED SOMETHING
THAT NOT MANY PEOPLE THOUGHT
COULD HAPPEN AND TO DO IT IN
FRONT OF OUR FAMILY, FRIENDS AND
FANS IT IS JUST
>> Kyle: AND A MAGICAL 2:47 FOR
YOU LAST SEASON AND TO BE A PART
OF THIS RUN, GOOD ENOUGH TO PLAY
EVERY GAME, WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO
YOU?
>> VALIDATION TO THE REHAB
SESSIONS AND ALL OF THE HARD
WORK AND TO MY FAMILY WHO HAVE
LOVED, SUPPORTED ME AND THE
TRAINING STAFF WHO HAVE NEVER
QUIT ON ME, TO BE A PART OF
THIS, LAST YEAR, AMAZING, THIS,
I THINK, TOPS
>> Chris: AND YOU THINK OF
STEVEN STAMKOS, HIP INJURIES,
LEG INJURIES, HE HAS GONE
THROUGH A LOT OF INJURIES.
>> Craig: AND BRAYDEN POINT,
WHAT A YEAR HE HAD, WHAT A GAME
HE HAD.
A NINE-GAME GOAL SCORING STREAK
AND A PASSOFF NOW TO ANOTHER
UNDERRATED PLAYER AND I THOUGHT
THAT ERIK CERNAK TURNING THE
CORNER, LAST YEAR HE HAD PLAYED
BUT NOT THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
THAT HE HAD THIS
>> Chris: AND FIVE OF THE TAMPA
BAY LIGHTNING ACQUIRED BY
AND THERE IS ANOTHER, RUTTA
TAKING THAT
>> Craig: AND JAN RUTTA, DID NOT
PLAY A LOT LAST YEAR AND HE WAS
AN INTEGRAL PART AND WITH HEDMAN
BACK THERE, YOU HAVE
TO LEARN AND HE WAS A SPONGE.
>> Chris: AND SCORED A GOAL IN
GAME THREE PUTTING MONTREAL
OFF-BALANCE AND ANOTHER YOUNG
DEFENSEMAN ACQUIRED FROM TRADE
AND THE MONTREAL CANADIENS KNEW
THAT THEY WERE TRADING A
TALENTED YOUNG GUY IN
MIKHAIL SERGACHEV.
>> Craig: INTERESTING THAT THREE
IN A ROW ARE THE "D" AND KYLE
SPOKE OF THE MONTREAL DEFENSE, A
FAMILY WITHIN THE FAMILY AND
HERE NOW CERNAK, RUTTA AND
SERGACHEV.
>> Chris: CIRELLI, HE WON A
MEMORIAL CUP IN OSHAWA, LIFTING
THE STANLEY CUP FOR THE SECOND
TIME.
KYLE?
>> Kyle: CHRIS, ALONG WIT
BRDE POINT TO DO THIS AGAIN,
BRADEN NBACK-TO-BACK YEAR, WITH
A CROWD LIKE THIS, WHAT ARE YOU
THINKING OF?
>> WELL, JUST HOW MUCH WORK IT
TOOK FROM ALL OF THE GUYS TO
COME BACK, TO HAVE A GOOD YEAR,
THE SACRIFICE THAT OUR GUYS
MADE, BLOCKED SHOTS AND JUST
EVERYTHING THAT IT HAD TAKEN TO
WIN AGAIN, INCREDIBLE, JUST
VERY, VERY PROUD OF THIS GROUP.
>> KyleSEEMS REMARKABLE,
CHEMISTRY BETWEEN PALAT,
KUCHEROV AND THE THREE OF YOU
AND HOW COULD YOU DESCRIBE WHAT
IS IN STORE FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS?
>> YES, WE'VE PLAYED A LOT
TOGETHER, ADVERSITY, HIGHS, LOWS
AND JUST GREAT, GREAT FRIENDS ON
THIS GROUP, A TIGHT GROUP, AS
YOU SAY AND WE
PLEASED TO PLAY TOGETHER, TO
WIN.
>> Kyle: WHAT MEANS THE MOST TO
YOU IN A MOMENT LIKE THIS?
>> JUST TO SHARE IT WITH
EVERYONE, THE CROWD TONIGHT,
ELECTRIC, A TEAM EFFORT, THE
FACT THAT YOU CAN SHARE THIS
WITH THE EAM, JUST FANTASTIC.
>> Chris: AND BARB UNDERHILL,
ONE OF THE SKATING COACHES, SHE
WORKS ALONG WITH TRACY AND AN
INTERESTING STORY THERE, THE TWO
SKATING COACHES, BOTH OF THEM
GROWING UP TOGETHER IN OSHAWA
AND THEY ARE A PART OF
THE CELEBRATION, MATHIEU JOSEPH
HANDING IT OFF TO CURTIS
McELHINNEY AND CURTIS AT 38
YEARS OF AGE, THE BACKUP
GOALTENDER, DOING LIKELY THE
MOST WORK IN THE PRACTICES, A
CUP CHAMPION FOR THE SECOND
STRAIGHT YEAR.
>> Craig: IT TAKES EVERYONE AND
I LOVE THAT MATHIEU JOSEPH GOT
AN OPPORTUNITY AND JON COOPER
SAID THAT HE DID NOT GET THE
CHANCE TO PLAY LAST YEAR AND
HERE HE PLAYED A SIGNIFICANT
ROLE HERE IN THE STANLEY CUP
FINAL AND NOW THE PLAYERS WHO